I’ve co-founded two YC companies and learned a
lot in the process, so here are my key takeaways
from Y Combinator. Start Small: It can be easy
to focus on big companies that you might be
competing with in the first days of starting a
company, but that’s a mistake. Big things have
small beginnings. Every company starts as
nothing more than an idea, but what makes
companies get really big is consistent compounding
growth over a long period of time. Growth rate is
by far the most important factor in a startup's
success. It’s what every venture capitalist values
most when considering an investment so you need to
start thinking about growth immediately. Focusing
on growth rates instead of absolute numbers
can be extremely motivating. This is because,
the smaller you are, the easier it is to
have a high growth rate. If you only have
a few hundred users, doubling that number in a
month is completely doable, and that will start
compounding pretty quickly. As you get bigger,
doubling every month might not be possible,
but 20% monthly growth is usually sustainable for
companies with strong product market fit, and 20%
monthly growth works out to a ten x increase over
a year. I’ve personally seen this with my YouTube
channel. The number of subscribers is still
really small, but I’ve been growing the channel
20% per month on a very consistent basis, which
is extremely promising. So if you’re watching this
and you’re not subscribed, please do me a favor
and help me keep that growth going. Y Combinator
is just 3 months long and many enter the program
with just an idea or basic prototype. Without
fail, the companies that get the most attention
at demo day have the highest growth rates. It’s
way better to be a company that went from making
$1,000 at the start of the program to $10,000 in
just 3 months, than be a company making a million
dollars without any growth. If you’re ever feeling
like you’re in a David vs Goliath situation,
going up against massive competitors, just compare
your growth rates. The biggest companies in the
world aren’t growing 10x in a year, but you can
if you build a great product that people
love. And that brings me to lesson number 2:
get into build mode. No job or college degree
can fully prepare you for being the founder of
a startup, they are all too specialized. Building
a company from scratch requires bringing together
so many different skills and this is one of
the hardest, but also most rewarding aspects
of entrepreneurship. Paul Graham says that “if you
want to start a startup, it’s good to know about
multiple, unrelated things. Startups often
depend on 4 or 5 different kinds of knowledge,
and it’s great if they can be all found in 2
founders” - it’s rare to start your company
already knowing about all the relevant
disciplines required to succeed though,
so that’s why it’s so important to get into build
mode. When I say “build mode” I mean being willing
to roll up your sleeves and learn the relevant
skills to accomplish the task in front of you.
You might be a great programmer, but no one will
sign up for the app you built if you can’t figure
out how to promote it. So you might need to learn
how to write compelling blog posts or run digital
ads in order to start growing. When I started my
first company, I wasn’t a very good programmer. I
was able to throw together basic prototypes, but
I didn’t have much experience actually growing a
digital product. So I spent months coding and
eventually got to a point where I was pretty
comfortable writing Python. I’m still not an
expert, but I know enough to be dangerous and that
helps me manage engineers effectively. My second
time through Y Combinator was a little different.
A few months before I started YC, I was managing a
large team at my previous company and had lots of
support. My day to day was mostly management and
I really wasn’t in that “builder” mindset anymore.
The first company had scaled to over 50 employees
and it didn’t make sense for me to spend time
writing code when I had a whole team of talented
developers who were way better than me. As soon as
YC started, I really focused on shifting back into
build mode. Since I was comfortable programming,
I spent time learning more about marketing and
branding. I figured out how to produce video
content, which is really valuable when you’re
selling products online, and also led to this
YouTube channel. You shouldn’t be afraid to learn
new things when you’re working on a startup.
You’re not going to be an expert, but learning
about a particular discipline will help immensely
when you eventually start hiring. All of this
will be a lot easier if you follow lesson 3: avoid
distractions. Starting a company is a full-time
endeavor. In some cases, you can get started
while still working a 9 to 5 or finishing college,
but once you start taking your startup seriously,
you’ll quickly realize the value of focus. When I
went through Y Combinator, moving to the bay area
was a requirement, and one that I really benefited
from. I was completely broke, which meant living
in a fun part of San Francisco was off the table.
I wound up moving to a run-down house in Sunnyvale
which isn’t exactly a nightlife hub. That was a
huge benefit though. With no distractions, I was
able to focus entirely on learning new things,
writing code, and testing startup ideas. I had
tried to work from other places but never had much
success. There are always fun events happening on
college campuses and working from a friend's house
wasn’t productive for me either. There is a lot of
discussion about burnout in the tech world, but
I don’t think that really applies to the early
days of a startup. If you’re working on a big idea
that you’re really passionate about, you shouldn’t
burn out. When I started my first company, I spent
plenty of late nights programming, but it didn’t
feel like work to me. I really enjoyed the process
of learning and building new things I thought of.
Now, this is all a lot harder if you’re
completely alone, which is why co-founders
are so important. And lesson 4 is to really focus
on building relationships with your co-founders.
The experience of building a startup is very
unique, and it can be hard to relate to if you
haven’t done it before. This is why entrepreneurs
love to work with venture capitalists who have
actually started companies before. And having
a team around you that feels the same way about
avoiding distractions and just building is so
important. But you don’t need to be spending
every waking hour working in front of a computer.
Getting to know your co-founders on a deeper level
is one of the most critical things you can do.
Ideally, you’ll already have experience working
with your co-founders when you start your company,
but it doesn’t matter if you’ve known each other
for years, or just a few months, you can always
build a stronger relationship. Understanding
what really motivates a person is vital to any
good working relationship, and motivation is a
complex and emergent property. Oftentimes, what
drives a person to build a startup could trace
back to their childhood or upbringing, and you
usually don’t get to know someone on that level
around the watercooler. Not every conversation has
to be a psychoanalysis, but building trust between
the co-founding team will pay dividends for years
if it’s done right. Plus, one of the amazing
things about bringing talented people together
is that their experiences can cross-pollinate one
another. In that Sunnyvale house we had people who
had studied economics, biology, computer science,
and electrical engineering. We had a great time
just hanging out and talking about what we had
each learned in college and trying to summarize
complex topics succinctly. Everyone has different
life experiences and sometimes great things
can come out of combining disciplines. Taking
advantage of these unique situations requires
being ready to iterate, which is lesson 5. We
tried dozens of startup ideas in that hacker house
and every time we iterated on our ideas we got a
little bit better. It’s always tricky to know
when to stay the course versus when to change
directions, but iteration doesn’t always have to
be a binary choice. You might have a crystal clear
vision of what your product should look like, but
if users don’t love it and you’re not growing,
something needs to change. You can’t be afraid
to iterate and course correct as needed. In 2012,
nothing was working for us. We spent
months building our first product,
only to completely flop when we launched. So we
increased our pace of iteration. The next product
we launched in just 3 weeks. It failed again, so
we decided to try and test a new idea every week.
By speeding up the pace of our iterations we
figured out what was actually required to get
feedback on new ideas. Ask yourself: do you need
to build the entire product before launching?
Or would a landing page do the trick? Sometimes
all you need is a blog post describing what you’re
planning to build. If there is real demand for
your solution, people will comment on your post
and encourage you to move forward. It’s useful
to set clear deadlines. Y Combinator is itself
essentially one big deadline: demo day. You need
to get up on stage and present your company to
hundreds of investors. Clear communication is a
must, so you have to iron out exactly what the
problem is and how you’ll solve it. You’re also
expected to show some metrics and they better be
up and to the right. YC has weekly dinners and
meetings with partners, which should force you
to start thinking about achievable milestones.
You never want to show up with zero progress
because you got distracted. Even if your latest
iteration takes you in a different direction,
that could still be solid progress if user
satisfaction has increased. One of the biggest
benefits of Y Combinator is the competition.
All the companies are on a level playing field:
3 months to deliver the most progress possible.
You should definitely have longer term goals in
mind, but thinking in weekly sprints can really
help keep you focused on what’s most important.
And at the early stage, there are really only
two things that are important: your product
and your users. Every week you want to be making
your product better in some tangible way and
then increasing the number of users getting real
value from your product. That “real value” part is
important. There are plenty of ways to game the
stats and make it look like you’re growing when
you’re really not. It’s vastly more important
to get a few dedicated users who really love
what you’re building as opposed to adding more and
more users who are indifferent about your product.
There are tons of activities that feel like work,
but actually do nothing to advance your company
at the early stage. When you’re just a team of
co-founders and an idea, you really need to resist
the urge to professionalize. This can be really
tempting, because there is immense social pressure
to fulfill a set of criteria for what “work” looks
like. Things like an office, business cards, and
fancy equipment will all make your company look
more professional, but might do nothing to improve
your product. If all of your friends work at big
companies, they might think you’re a complete joke
for spending all day coding in a run-down hacker
house. Although that’s changed a bit over the last
year. Getting an office or business cards may make
you feel like you’re more of a “real” company,
but for many startups, the customer just doesn’t
care about the company behind the product,
they just want it to work. Pretty much every YC
company is a mess behind the scenes. No one has it
all figured out from day one, so don’t stress over
this. Every successful company goes through rough
patches and has to work through difficult issues.
Entrepreneurship is never easy. But spending time
and money trying to make yourself look more
professional than you are is often a waste of
time. To be fair, certain businesses might need
office space earlier than others, or business
cards to sell into enterprises at conferences,
but you should really think about whether what
you’re doing will have an immediate impact on
your startup. And that brings me to lesson 8:
you need to learn how to synthesize advice
from different sources. This one is a bit meta,
but you have to develop a skill for assessing
what’s actually relevant to your startup. It’s not
uncommon to hear an amazing story from a unicorn
founder during YC and think that you need to apply
their strategy to your business, but this can be
a mistake. YC has lots of incredible partners,
each with their own unique startup experiences.
These experiences obviously affect the advice
that they give and you need to figure out how to
apply new ideas to your business specifically. No
one will ever know your startup as well as you do,
so you shouldn’t be afraid to discount a certain
lesson about startups if you think it just doesn’t
apply. Now, startup advice comes in many forms.
Some is extremely high level and battle tested
throughout decades. This is advice like “build
something people want” or “pursue a big market”.
Those recommendations are pretty hard to argue
with, since they are so useful. It would be
very odd to try and build a startup based on
the idea of “building something people don’t
want” - but hey, nothing’s impossible. Where
you want to be more discerning is when it comes
to tactical startup advice, like go-to-market
strategy. The best way to launch a new startup
is constantly evolving, so recommendations like
“create a high-production value video” don’t last
too long. As soon as a specific growth strategy
becomes widely known, it usually stops working.
Once every startup is making launch videos,
they lose their effectiveness. YC can be a bit
like drinking from a firehose. You’re getting a
constant torrent of feedback about what you’re
building, and that can be intense at times. If
you’re not doing well, you’ll know it. That’s why
this last lesson is so important: Enjoy Yourself
Startups are a long journey. Dustin Moskovitz,
who co-founded Facebook, was once asked what it
was like to be part of an “overnight success” like
Facebook. I still love his answer, he said: "If by
'overnight success' you mean staying up and coding
all night, every night for six years straight,
then it felt quite tiring and stressful."
No matter how fast your company is growing,
there will always be a ton of work. In
fact, oftentimes, the faster you grow
the more work you’ll have to do. There are
always growing pains to work through and
you’ll be constantly inundated with challenges.
That’s why it’s so important to try and find
a problem that you really love working on.
And I’m not just talking about the mission.
My first company was in the education technology
space, and I thought the idea of helping people
learn would be extremely energizing. The goal was
exciting, but the day-to-day of trying to sell
products to schools was completely unsatisfying
to me. In order to be able to stay motivated for
years, you need to love the mission, the industry,
and the day-to-day. This means you should never
chase trends. Even if you see a certain
type of company getting funded every month,
you shouldn’t even think about starting a
company in that industry unless you’re really
passionate about the space and could see yourself
really thriving in that environment for years.
If you want to chat about YC, just leave
me a comment below or DM me on Twitter,
and please check out this recommended video, the
YouTube algorithm thinks you’ll really like it.